[Music]
tonight's Common Ground segment features
two congressmen from Texas Republican
Jake Elsey and Democrat Colin Allred
thank you gentlemen for both being here
really appreciate it you both serve on
the Veterans Affairs committee and
Congressman all right I'll talk to you
first you both traveled with President
Biden on Air Force One to visit a
facility in in Texas about The Pact act
and that's one of the things you work on
together in a bipartisan way that's
right Brett you know the PAC deck is all
about expanding coverage to folks who've
been exposed to toxins while serving
abroad and you know I think the idea was
basically that they shouldn't have to
prove that their illnesses that they
then incur later are service related
that we should just assume that and you
know obviously Jake with his service I
think knows what goes into that and so I
was glad that we were able to work
together on that that's not the only
thing we've worked on on the Veterans
Affairs committee we have really I think
great relationship and ability to work
on those kinds of things and I really
appreciate that because I think it's
important that we take care of our
veterans and it should be bipartisan
yeah Congressman Elsie there's other
bills as Congressman Allred mentioned
the major VA facilities act we do these
Common Ground segments because there is
a lot of common ground up there that
actually gets passed left and right
there's so much of that that actually
happens but it doesn't make the clicks
happen you know we Cullen and I are
actually neighbors our districts are
neighbors he's in in Dallas County I'm
to the south of him and we've worked
very well together we've partnered with
each other to get a spinal cord injury
facility at the VA in Dallas and we've
also worked to to get a new facility in
El Paso and you know when we talk about
what brings Common Ground here in the
United States everybody agrees that we
should be taking care of our veterans in
a better and and more substantial way
and we work very hard on that so when
the President says I want to help
veterans we're all on board with that
and that is the bright shining star
about our nation is we come together to
talk about that but it doesn't get a
whole lot of attention and it should
yeah immigration is sometimes something
that drives people apart up there on
Capitol Hill all kinds of different
takes on it Congressman Allred I read
that you look at the issue uh from a
Texan point of view uh with your fellow
congressman and do you see eye to eye on
a lot of the issues there when it comes
to immigration yeah I think we probably
do I think we also understand that our
Texas border communities are just that
you know their communities and they have
real needs and they've been under stress
with the number of migrants that have
been coming and that we need to Surge
resources to that area that we need to
do much better on our ability to process
Asylum claims yes you know border
security is an important component of
that and then we also have to address at
the root cause what's driving so much of
this migration particularly from Central
America and you know collapsing
countries like Venezuela and so you know
I think Jake and I both understand is
Texans The Strain that puts on our state
but also so the human factor and that's
something that you know even if we don't
agree on every single detail I'm sure we
agree on the broader points
yeah is there something Congressman
Elsie that can be done legislatively I
mean considering and we've talked to a
number of Democrats who feel like
Congressman Allred about uh you know
doing something even around the edges if
you look these stats immigrants with
criminal records released into the U.S
just for December you've got criminal
convictions 515 facing charges 641 so
you're talking about roughly 1200
immigrants with criminal records
released into the U.S and their
communities you know a lot of them are
in Texas in Arizona and other border
states feeling some of that most of them
are coming up through Texas and there's
three there's three parts of the Border
issue that are extremely troubling and
keep this in mind they're all controlled
by the cartels the 4.6 million illegal
immigrants who have come through in the
last two years uh sending boys and girls
men and women across the border for the
purposes of the sex trade which is
modern day slavery and then finally the
Fentanyl and drugs that come across that
are killing our 18 to 45 year olds
faster than anything else in World War
II we lost 400 118 000 Americans
fighting World War II in three and a
half years that's 305 a day today we
lost 100 this last year we lost 105 000
Americans to drug overdose two-thirds of
that from fentanyl all of which comes
from China That's 287 people every day
and when we're talking about uh threats
that's the alligator closest canoe
they're killing Americans at wartime
rates in our bedrooms in our backyards
and it must be addressed
you mentioned China Congressman Allred
you tweeted out uh we must always be
United to ensure America can remain
competitive lead the world in Commerce
and Innovation you're both on the same
page about this committee dealing with
China that Congressman Gallagher is
going to head up right that's right Brad
you know I voted for it I'm a member of
the Foreign Affairs committee as well
I've visited the Indo paycom region not
long ago including going to Taiwan I
know exactly the threat that China poses
to us on many different fronts but I
also know that we can approach it really
from a cold war perspective that we need
to out-compete them and as I've been on
the Foreign Affairs committee and
traveling around the world I've seen
that whether it's Africa or Latin
America people want to work more with
the United States but we have to be more
present yes militarily but also with our
soft power and I hope that this
committee can help us you know try and
stand up ways for us to compete on every
single front I think the chips bill that
we passed in the last Congress will help
us along that way in some regards in
terms of our own semiconductor
production but there's so many areas
that we need to confront them on and out
compete them
yeah and Congressman Elsie I only have a
few seconds here but you agree with that
and high hopes for this committee
absolutely and I think this transcends
party lines as well this is about the
United States staying the predominant
economic power in the world China wants
to supplant that both militarily and
economically and make their their uh
their Yuan the reserve uh uh dollar if
you will and supplant us on that so we
have to work very very well together and
everybody's on board for that right now
as Americans
yeah we don't look through rose-colored
glasses we like to point out where you
are working together but there's a lot
of stuff that obviously you'll battle
about all right I just want to continue
our conversation you know when you talk
about China it seems like there is a lot
of bipartisan
um back and forth up there and what
Congress can do is really the question
Congressman alright well I think that's
right I think there are a number of
areas where we know uh the Chinese are
trying to take advantage of
international law and try and work their
way into the U.N work their way into the
who other areas where I think we need to
make sure that we're present and so I
think we can fund projects like that we
also have to deter them in the Pacific
and I think Jake and I will certainly I
think be in agreement around that they
have grown their military capabilities
significantly in recent years it does
look like they're preparing to be able
to invade Taiwan the best way for us to
prevent that I think is to be strong
enough to deter them so that we don't
have to use uh you know the seventh
fleet out there in that region
yeah Congressman Elsie you know we talk
about getting things done across party
lines but it doesn't get talked about a
lot on Capitol Hill because a lot of
times the parties uh even though they
agree on some elements of bills they go
to their Corners uh to fight over
something else for somebody that's not
in Washington can you explain this
phenomena you know how this happens well
I think it's it's largely driven by the
things that you choose to look at on
your phone or on your news media uh
boring isn't isn't something that's
going to get a lot of clicks and whether
you're in the Texas legislature where I
was before this or in Congress the true
bipartisan things don't fit the
narrative that people need to sell
things on so if you're on Instagram or
Tick Tock or or Twitter the algorithm is
going to send you towards what you look
at and if and if you you want to be
outraged you'll find that and then it's
going to send it to you so people that
are boring don't get a heck of a lot of
attention you know and cooperation and
Mission accomplishment sometimes gets
boring for some people and it occurs I
tell people back at home 80 percent of
the folks up here may disagree but
they'll get along while doing it they'll
disagree without being disagreeable uh
and and and so as a military guy I've
always told my constituents that it's
about quiet professionalism and Mission
accomplishment and anybody wants to work
with me and Colin on on bettering the
lives of our veterans who have signed up
and and chosen to give so much to our
country I'm all on board with that and
I'll work with anybody and I think most
issues are like that and Colin and I'll
see each other in in the in the chamber
and and just say hello how you doing and
that happens a lot more than people
might think and my message is one of
Hope for this country I think our
brighter days are ahead and Congress
doesn't always work well but it works
better than people might think and
certainly more cooperatively and civilly
than what you might see most of the time
yeah so listen our viewers have have
welcomed this segment I get a lot of
email a lot of tweets and a lot of
messages about you know just hearing
this and even though sometimes it is
boring into the weeds of bipartisan
negotiation Congressman Allred uh you
got to talk about it because everything
we hear and everything and to be fair to
Congressman Elsie's Point everything the
media focuses on is usually the conflict
the thing that drives people up that
drives clicks
um but but it does happen that you have
relationships across the aisle it does
and yes like you said we don't have
rose-colored glasses there are things
that Jake and I are certainly going to
disagree upon I think what Jake said is
right though we won't do it disagreeably
and I I think that's actually really
important it's not just because we're
neighbors it's not just because we're
both bald guys uh you know I think I
think it's because we have a fundamental
level of respect for each other I don't
question uh you know Jake's motives uh
and I think that's actually really
important because I think when you start
from that you know kind of basis you can
try and find some common areas of
agreement but what we do have a lot of
and it's unfortunate we do is a complete
questioning of the rationale the motives
of the character you know of our
colleagues and that makes once you have
that you're not really going to find
Common Ground after that
I feel left out here the only person
with him that's all right we can say we
can teach you how to shave your
headphones yeah
all right I don't know how that would go
for me but we'll see um I want to ask
you one more thing one of the things
that that at least both parties are
setting up that it's going to be
controversial is this debt selling
increase uh and what comes out of it you
know when President Biden was Senator
Biden he was on the other side saying
that the Republicans should compromise
and should make some concessions he's
now at least the administration is
suggesting that that's not the case
right now how do you ball both see this
uh Congressman Ellis reversed and then
Congressman well it's a great question
and I would like to point out to our
viewers that this this issue is going to
take some time but nothing happens until
June with the debt ceiling I'm going to
be on Appropriations Committee net going
into next cycle and I think what you're
seeing is both sides working against
each other in the media realm to get
their point across the idea that
remember according to the Constitution
the House of Representatives has the
power of the purse so there's no money
to get it's spent that doesn't go
through their house first including how
the executive branch operates and how
and and what it gets to accomplish so
there will have to be negotiations about
that because the Republicans are in
charge in the House of Representatives
and that's where all spending bills
originate so uh he will have to
negotiate I think that this is just part
of the back and forth that goes on uh
during the the the negotiations process
but he will have to and we need to get
our fiscal house in order for the first
time since 1946 our debt is higher than
our GDP that's not a Glide path that is
sustainable so we have to get our fiscal
house in order
so this is laying the groundwork is the
argument there Congressman Allred your
thoughts well you know listen this is
going to be one of the things that Jake
and I disagree about and I think that
either party really should not you know
play uh with this issue uh because it
the consequences for us are so dire and
because we've seen how this plays out
when we go right up to the edge uh back
in 2012 and we saw our credit rating uh
downgraded you know raising interest
rates for folks basically costing us
more money brinksmanship to me isn't the
same thing as negotiations I do think
that we'll have to have bipartisan
negotiations around our spending that's
obvious with the house being controlled
by Republicans but that doesn't mean
that I think the debt ceiling is the
best mechanism for that because what
you're really doing I think in that case
is I think some folks would agree is
hostage taking in a way because you're
saying if we don't get our way then this
really terrible outcome is going to
occur so listen I I'm with Jake in terms
of us you know controlling our spending
being able to work within you know the
realm of what I think is you know
prudent use of taxpayer dollars but I
don't think the debt selling is the
right mechanism and listen I I we're
having this conversation Jake and are
gonna be friends after we walk out of
here talking about it it's okay that we
disagree on it and like I said we'll
hopefully do it without being
disagreeable right and if I may I don't
I haven't heard the speaker say anything
about the debt ceiling being held
hostage I just think that the spending
issues uh the the power of the purses we
go forward is something we need to
address uh and and I think that that
we're going to do that as as Kevin
McCarthy has said our three biggest
threats are China the debt and our
educational system and and so we're
we're going to go after those three
things
so you think regular order is possible
this year regular order is what we have
called for they're in the rules now and
uh and I think we're going to have 12
spending bills uh and that's that is the
goal and we're telling the Senate we're
going to send you 12 spending bills we
expect to get 12 spending spending bills
back regular order does need to come
back so we don't have a an Omnibus again
we've reached the point at which we
can't afford to do that anymore and and
I think the American people I think we
can all agree on that for to some level
and uh and so but nobody wants us to to
default on our debt or lose our credit
rating uh that's I've never heard
anybody say that that's something
anybody wants
well we'll track it and we will
appreciate the time coming on Common
Ground both of you thank you Brett
you can catch common ground on the Brett
Bear podcast wherever you download
podcasts Fox newspodcast.com Spotify and
leave a rating and review we want to
hear from you we'll see you next time